as the war rages in ukraine officials in
state-run media and russia paint a very
different picture of what's happening
for one thing they insist the invasion
which has isolated the country and
already costs thousands of lives isn't
an invasion at all mts type is following
moscow's propaganda effort
this unreality is now the law of the
land across russia with words like war
or invasion banned and anyone accused of
spreading quote false information about
the russian military facing up to 15
years in prison that's led the last
remaining independent russian news
channels to close
russia is becoming an absolutely
isolated state
it really looks like north korea to me
was an anchor for tv reign and has now
fled russia she says russians are only
being told one story
the message is clear and very simple
that nato is right around the corner
that nature is threatening russia
across the country protests are being
crushed with an iron fist monitoring
groups say around fourteen thousand
anti-war protesters have been detained
since the start of the invasion
is a sitting russian lawmaker how do you
think president putin's war on ukraine
is going our government tell us that
middle declaration is going
pretty
well you keep referring it to as a
military operation but this is an
invasion this is a war you and a huge
part of
western world live in a world of
ukrainian myths
what's undeniable is support for the
military remains high the letter z
initially used by russian forces to
identify its own on the battlefield has
quickly become a potent pro-war
propaganda tool for the kremlin
this letter it's a symbol and it's scary
it's frightening it looks almost like
this
swastika
symbol
a u.s official has told cbs news between
five and six thousand russian soldiers
may have been killed since fighting
began
has the invasion of ukraine been worth
all that russia is now experiencing you
know uh we are proud nation
and we love our country we have no
any other motherland
and we must
protect it
now the kremlin has been working really
hard to stoke that sense of nationalism
across russia in fact just this morning
the foreign minister said moscow never
wants to rely on the west ever again
nancy
mta's in london thank you so much